Hi Guys.
So a quick update.
Okay,
now I'm going to be having a debate
Saturday at nine 30 in the morning
eastern standard time and it will be
live cast on Jordan Peterson videos on
youtube.
The participants will be Mayo Moran,
who's the moderator,
she's a professor of law and the provost
at Trinity College,
University of Toronto.
I'll be debating Mary Bryson,
who's a professor of education and
senior Associate Dean Administration and
innovation at the University of British
Columbia.
And Brenda Cossman,
who is professor of law and director of
the bottom center for sexual diversity
studies at the University of Toronto.
She'll undoubtedly telling me that I
don't really understand bill [inaudible]
and the legislation that I'm commenting
on,
but we'll see about that.
So of course,
since the debate has been announced,
the PC authoritarians are in an uproar
because,
um,
well as Huffington Post Canada blogger
idle Khatri pointed out,
the university met my demands for
holding a public debate.
Well,
I want to just mention a few things
about that because he,
first of all,
he doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about.
And so,
well,
let's just say that he's uninformed.
I didn't demand that the university
holds a debate.
I met with the Dean after receiving two
letters from the university warning me
to stop doing what I was doing and I
suggested given the uproar that
surrounded the videos,
that there was something that should be
talked out in that the university could
perhaps models civilized conversation
about such complex topics.
And so I was in no position to demand
anything.
So it's typical of of I would say the PC
authoritarian ideology or idealogue
misuse of language.
You can bend the story too to suit your
perspective without really giving any
second thought to the truth.
And of course he commented the
University of Toronto is providing yet
another stage for spreading uninformed
fear and hate.
Well you can make what you want out of
that.
I don't know what exactly he means by
yet another stage.
I mean they certainly didn't provide me
with my first stage and of course I
wasn't spreading uninformed fear and
hate to begin with.
But I would say that's just typical of
of the behavior of,
of the people on the PC authoritarian
part of the political spectrum.
So what else is new?
Well,
Leonard Cohen died,
so that really was too bad because he
was great.
That's the big news in Canada.
And then of course Donald Trump was
elected this week.
Sorry to keep you waiting.
Complicated business.
Copper
can.
Why was that?
Well,
there were a variety of reasons,
of course,
but I think that the simplest
explanation was that in in the mid
seventies the Democrats,
they abandoned the working class to play
identity politics.
And that's too bad because of the
working class.
Reagan needs a voice in politics.
And part of the reason for that is that
there is a proclivity in societies for,
for the winter to take all fundamentally
in in monetary circumstances.
And so that accounts for the rise,
not so much of the 1% but if the one
10th of one 10th of 1% and it is a
constant societal battle to ensure that
economic resources are funneled in some
manner down to the people who were near
the bottom of the dominance hierarchy.
So the working class needs a voice,
but it's not the Democrats and that's
why the rust belt abandoned them and
cost Hillary Clinton the election.
They identity politics.
People are not interested in the
individual.
This is sort of their defining
characteristic.
And for them,
group membership is all that counts.
I was thinking today,
if you told the Kentucky Coal Miner this
story about people demanding their own
pronouns,
the first thing he'd think is,
man,
I'm voting trump.
And you know,
it's,
it's hardly surprising.
So anyhow,
that's what happened in the u s so back
to the,
to the topic at hand,
I want to review with a pc game again,
and this is,
this is the game that the Democrats have
been playing,
especially on the left.
Instead of focusing as they should be
focusing on the economic concerns of
people who are disadvantaged regardless
of their group identity.
To play the VC game,
you identify an area of human activity
that can be any area of human activity
from sports to economic activity.
You know that there's a distribution of
success in that area of activity like
there is in every human activity.
There's some people who are good at
whatever it is that's being done in some
people who were less good and of course
the people who are good at it do better
in the people who are not as good do
worse,
so you identify the winners and the
losers.
Then you claimed that the losers are
losing because they're oppressed by the
winners.
That way you can dispense with any such
thing as competence,
for example,
or failed to notice the effect that say
hard work has on fostering success.
I know that there are campuses in the
United States now where it's considered
a microaggression to make the claim that
people who work hard make more money
than people who don't work hard anyways.
You can also claim.
Then once you've claimed that the losers
are losing because they're oppressed by
the winners,
you can claim unearned allegiance with
the losers.
Feel secure in your comprehensive
explanation of the world because you've
got everything wrapped up.
You've got five axioms.
That's all you need.
You can explain everything with them.
Then you can revel in your moral
superiority and you have the additional
benefit of being able to target your
resentment towards your newly discovered
enemies.
So any rot or blackness that you happen
to be harboring in your soul,
you can vent towards these people that
are hypothetical oppressors and that
that means that you can be a terrible
person and you can feel good about it at
the same time.
Then you can repeat that forever in
every possible circumstance everywhere,
and that's the PC gate.
Now,
we've been looking into that fair bit
with our research.
I'm working very hard with my graduate
student,
Christine Brophy right now,
my phd student trying to get our first
paper on political correctness ready for
release,
but I can give you some,
some more,
some information about it.
We did a video with rebel media about,
we weren't as articulate as we might've
been about it,
so I'm going to give it another shot
here.
So,
Oh,
before I do that,
another element of the PC game,
this is part of the pc philosophy
defined injustice as any equality of
outcome.
I would like to give you an update about
the University of Toronto Human Resource
and Equity Department's training
material.
They decided they were going to make
antibiose and antiracism training
mandatory for their staff and I made my
second video back in late September
about that and somebody slipped the
training material underneath my door.
And one of the things I found out that
was absolutely distressing was that the
consultant who was hired to do the
antiracism and antibiose training was
attempting to teach,
let's say.
But I would say indoctrinate the staff
into how to analyze a,
an organization to decide if it was a
oppressive.
And so basically what you do is you take
the organization,
imagine that it's a pyramid and it has
different strata.
Then you assess each strata,
you assess it demographically,
so you assess it by group identity,
race,
gender and so forth.
I suppose sexual preference and all the
other things that the PC authoritarians
like to go on and on about constantly
and defined people.
And then you match each strata of the
organization against the general
population.
And if the demographics don't match
exactly.
So if there aren't say 51% women and 2%
gay people and maybe 6% native people
and whatever,
whatever makes up the population,
then you define the organization as
inequitable and regarded as corrupt and
in need of modification.
There's obvious problems with that.
Not least.
That being,
that quality of outcome is perhaps the
most pernicious of Marxist doctrines.
And the attempt to impose that on entire
populations in the Soviet Union and in
Mao's China resulted in the deaths of
millions of people and we collect the
Cold War to stop claims that he,
quality of outcome was the,
was the optimal metric by which to
measure society's progress.
So that's the University of Toronto hr
department.
They're not at equity.
Not only are they taking advice from a
group of radicals who won't disavow
violence in their pursuit of social
change,
but now they're basically pushing what
can only be called communist propaganda
from like the 1930s on their employees.
It's absolutely appalling.
Kelly Hannah Moffit,
who's the vice president of human
resources and equity should promptly
resigned.
So a little bit about the historical
basis of these,
uh,
ideas.
I would say that the political correct
authoritarian types are fundamentally
influenced by two philosophers.
One,
Karl Marx,
uh,
who was the father of communism and his
basic principle was from each according
to his ability to each according to his
need.
Now that sounds good.
And it was a good enough slogan to
attract the attention of intellectuals
everywhere in to other people as well.
The problem comes in its practical
application and the problem is who
determines what constitutes need?
Because it's very,
very difficult to decide if my need say,
because I have a father with Alzheimer's
is greater than your need because you
have a daughter with cancer and a wife
who's an alcoholic.
So who the hell parses up need?
And,
and the problem of course also is the
need is infinite.
And it's also no easy matter to
determine whether or not each person is
contributing according to his or her
ability.
And that's partly why we have a free
market because these sorts of things
cannot be determined by central
authorities.
And as soon as they are,
then all hell breaks loose.
And the other part of the PC philosophy
horror show is Jacques Derrida and
Jacques Derrida,
I think was the most dangerous person
who lived in the 20th century.
Well maybe not because he had to compete
with Hitler and mio and Stalin.
So maybe that's a bit of an
overstatement.
It probably is.
Darin,
I think.
I think you might describe him as a
philosopher of extreme resentment and
he's a real trickster.
He basically claimed that human
categorization is for exclusion.
And so the postmodernist,
he's a postmodernist,
basically claimed that there's no truth,
there's only competing power games
essentially.
And that the reason that you categorize
the reason that human beings categorize
is to further their power games.
And so categorization is for exclusion.
You don't form a club so much to keep
people in as to keep people out to,
and that's part of your power game.
And that's of course absolutely
ridiculous because one of the things
that happens when you categorize is for
is that you exclude things.
Otherwise every category contains
everything that exists.
And so what the hell good is a category
like that.
Obviously categories exclude the idea
that that's why we categorize is
preposterous.
We categorize to simple simplify the
world so that we can operate on it
properly.
And so we generalize across discreet
entities so that we don't have to deal
with every single discreet entity.
And the reasons that we categorize are
quite complex.
We tend to categorize things in the same
category if they can be used for the
same purpose because we're basically
tool using creatures.
We don't so much categorize because
things have the same objective
properties because things have many
objective properties and so,
but we do tend to categorize things as
similar if they can be used for similar
purposes.
That's an extension of our tool using
capacity into the cognitive domain and
dare to also claimed essentially that
there's nothing outside the text and so
for the postmodernists everything
fundamentally is interpretation.
Everything is subjective and you can see
that reflected say and legislation like
bill see 16 which which insists that
gender identity and identity in general
I would say is only subjectively defined
which is of course also observed because
your identity is something that you
negotiate with other people.
If you're older than two,
and I mean that technically because two
year olds are egocentric and they have a
hard time negotiating anything with
other children and they can't really
learn to do that until there were about
three and and most kids are pretty good
at it by the age of four but if they
don't get it by the age of four,
then it's very difficult for them to
make friends for the rest of their life.
They,
they get excluded from the peer groups
and then they don't stay abreast of
their peers and they end up up alienated
and often antisocial.
It's really not good to construe.
Identity isn't only subjective,
is unbelievably psychologically and
philosophically primitive.
And the other thing about identity that
should be noted is that identity also
has functional utility.
So if you're,
if you have a genuine identity,
so if you're an artist,
say,
or a lawyer or a businessman or a
plumber or a nurse or a physician,
you're identity is something that,
it's a set of skills that you use to
operate in the social and the natural
world.
And so there's plenty outside the text.
Anyways,
I was thinking today about who Karl Marx
and Jacques Derrida would produce as a,
as a child,
as an offspring,
if they ever were able to meet
successfully.
And this is what I came up with.
Yeah,
it'd be the joker.
And,
and here's why.
Here's a great scene from the Batman
movie that's each herd Heath Ledger,
who really had the horror of resentment
down to a,
to a science.
Oh,
so could I say I?
So look,
I told you I'm a man of my word.
Where is he?
Italian.
Well,
I'll talk to [inaudible] to verge on the
location in 20 minutes.
I want auxiliary units to cover all
possible get away routes.
Please don't go to mind what you'll go
with all your money.
You see how the guy have simple taste.
I enjoy,
yeah,
dynamite and gunpowder and gasoline
and you know a thing that they have in
common.
Eric sheet
all I am,
I'm only burning my half.
All you care about is money deserves a
better class.
I'm going to give it the don't
tell you're mad thing work for me.
This is my setting
so you can see that when the joke or
does get his share of the money,
he doesn't want to use it for anything.
It's not the point.
The point is to gather it so that it can
be destroyed.
Just to show that all he is is a
destroyer and there are plenty of people
who were only destroyers and I certainly
regard the malevolent and of the Pc
Authoritarians as fundamental
destroyers.
They want to bring down everything
because the resentful,
they're resentful right to the core and
that's a very powerful human motivation.
You see that reflected,
for example,
in the biblical story of Cain and Abel,
which is really the story of the first
two human beings because Adam and eve
were made by God.
So the story goes,
Cain and Abel were the first genuine
human beings and they instantly lock
themselves into a murderous embrace
where one was very resentful of the
other success and uh,
ended up in fact killing him despite the
fact that he was his ideal.
That's a cautionary tale for everyone.
So I want to tell you a little bit about
our research.
So we took 192 political items,
uh,
that we gathered by analyzing what had
been discussed in the media as elements
or instances of political correctness.
We tried to be agnostic about it and
gather as many statements as we possibly
could.
And then we subjected them to a
statistical procedure called a factor
analysis,
which helps sort beliefs into their
categories.
And two beliefs go in the same category.
If,
if you agree with one,
you're likely to agree with the other or
if you disagree with when you're likely
to disagree with another,
you can see patterns of covariants it's
called,
but patterns of similarity within data
sets and it's an agnostic pro process
because it's,
it's purely computational.
It's an eight I would say it's about as
atheoretical approaches can possibly be.
Matt managed in in a science,
we found that there were two clumps of
politically correct belief.
We called one pc liberalism and here's a
couple of examples of things that pc
liberals particularly belief.
Other question would be rate the degree
to which you think the following
constitute evidence of an unjust system.
If you're a PC liberally,
you believe that societies in just
because or unjust because only 5% of the
fortune 500 companies have women as
ceos.
Because in 2013 the poverty rate for
blocks in the U s was 27% well for
whites it was 10% and because 64% of
physicians and surgeons are men in the
United States.
So that means that societies unjust pc
liberals agree with such things as the
world is warming because of the human
species burns too much fossil fuel
believe that racial,
ethnic and gender quota should exist in
employment.
Believe that government interventions
should exist in schools and companies to
ensure equality and professions where
there's a historically large inequality.
So that's partly quality of outcome.
That's the beliefs that clump together
to make the set of beliefs that we
described this pc liberalism.
And so here's what the PC authoritarians
look like.
They are in favor of censorship.
So they believe that books,
including the dictionary,
movies and art should be censored for
offensive slash racist slash sexist
discriminatory language and ideas.
So they're pro censorship.
They believe in punishment.
For Racist,
sexist,
or homophobic slurs.
And they also believe in retooling the
justice system.
So for example,
they believe that an alleged perpetrator
of sexual assault should have to prove
his or her innocence,
reversing the standard western legal
doctrine of innocent before proven
guilty.
They believe that students suspected of
sexual assault should be suspended
pending further investigation.
So that means that a suspicion is
sufficient to disrupt someone's life.
And they believe that is wrong,
to criticize the status and rights of
women under Islam because that is racist
and disrespectful of multiculturalism.
So that's the PC authoritarian set of
beliefs.
Here's what predicts whether or not you
believe those things.
So if you,
if you're going to believe the set of
beliefs that characterizes pc
liberalism,
then the best predictors were that you
had attended a politically correct
seminars.
So that shows you exactly how powerful
propaganda is.
And,
and the answer is very,
you're verbally intelligent.
So the more verbally intelligent you
are,
the more you believe the PC liberal line
you're hiring openness.
And that's a big five trait that's
associated with creativity.
You're agreeable,
particularly compassionate.
So agreeableness is another big five
train that's associated,
I would say with maternal behavior,
especially on the compassionate and
you're more likely to be female,
you're more likely to be educated and
you're more likely to be gay.
Whereas if you're a PC authoritarian,
you have low verbal intelligence and and
low intelligence in general,
high disgust sensitivity.
And that's been associated with
conservatism in the past.
So the pc out there tarion's or are
weird,
a hybrid between agreeableness say
which,
which puts them on a pc spectrum and the
same kind of orderliness and disgust
sensitivity that seemed to characterize
right wing authoritarians.
Ah,
you're more likely to be nonwhite
religious with a low income female
diagnosed with an anxiety or mood
disorders.
So that might account for the desire for
space,
a safe spaces and such things.
A agreeable,
compassionate down,
polite.
And again,
the best way to think about
agreeableness is as a maternal
dimension.
And that's I think why pc people treat
everyone as if there are children and
you're conscientious but orderly,
orderly,
not,
not industrious.
These factors are only correlated at
0.12.
So these are not the same people.
And we think the PC liberals are
basically apologists for the PC
authoritarians,
so I want to read you a letter that I
received recently,
the details that I just wanted to say.
Thanks for standing up for your beliefs
for others and for free speech in the
face of what I know must be a very
continuous and publicly attempted
shaming.
I'm a liberal and a feminist in my late
thirties until a few weeks ago when I
begin checking out your videos.
I would have described myself as a third
wave feminist.
I graduated from the University of
British Columbia with a major in biology
and a minor in women's studies.
I believe I was part of the early wave
of this pc authoritarian indoctrination.
The difference being I remember being
encouraged to have open dialogue back
then in my women's studies classes,
we didn't have trigger warnings are safe
spaces that came later.
I ended up finding myself working in
entertainment,
which I now believe is influenced
heavily by academia.
For the past 15 years or so,
I've managed careers of Comedians and
I've always been drawn to comedians with
a message having adored folks like Bill
Hicks,
Richard Pryor and George Carlin.
Overtime comedians with a message
eventually came to me comics who are
living in this social justice or your
bubble as am I.
For almost 20 years I lived in this echo
chamber and watched as social justice
academic concepts grew to mainstream
influence,
which I applaud it but at some point it
started realize that in these concepts
of equality and inclusion,
at least in my online world have morphed
into this strange cult of belief that
discourages descent discussion or free
speech and thought.
As I mentioned,
most of this came after I graduated so I
saw it unfold online.
I think social media for all of the good
is it has brought us,
has allowed us to become more isolated
than ever before possible.
My entire facebook and twitter feeds are
full of sjws.
This is the echo chamber I self selected
and most of them are in an all out
assault on differing opinions and on
each other.
Right now
perhaps because of the result of the U s
election.
There are a few of us within my echo
chamber who are trying to share a
thoughtful articles that attempt to
answer the question,
how did trump get elected?
No matter the nuanced and intelligent
content of these articles or the pains
too,
which I'm seeing folks try and present
them in a non offensive way to anyone
who may not agree the sjws are
cannibalizing these folks.
To be clear,
these are also liberals who have been
considered a part of the same community
until now who are being thrown out,
unfriended and ganged up on in this
social media public shaming way.
Now you see that's a good indication of
why I'm reading this letter.
It's because our research indicates that
there are two clumps of belief in the pc
cap,
the liberal type beliefs,
but but they're strongly influenced by
trait agreeableness,
which is not the case with with let's
say normal liberalism and the PC
authoritarians and there are strange
bedfellows,
let's,
let's put it that way and they don't
really agree and given the opportunity,
the PC authoritarians will eat the PC
liberals.
So this is a warning to upc liberal
types.
You should stop apologizing and acting
as intelligent and articulate
mouthpieces for the PC authoritarians.
They are not your friends and they're
pro censorship and this throwing people
out cannibalizing as as mentioned in
this letter is precisely the attempt to
impose a censorship on their so called
allies while they aren't your allies.
And that's exactly what you're seeing.
These are allies doing their best to try
to understand why trump won so we can
best change course and sway people to
our liberal point of view and they are
being told that they need to check their
privilege,
that they are only posting these things
because if they're unconscious racism.
Yeah.
That's the sort of thing that the
University of Toronto is trying to train
their staff out of,
that they are part of the white
supremacist culture and that they are
not allies,
et cetera.
It saddens me because I now believe it's
this kind of censorship and divisiveness
and willingness to write people off by
putting them in a bigot box that caused
the trump backlash to begin with.
I think these folks unconsciously
actually,
yeah,
well I'm not so sure it's unconscious,
but it might be pushing more and more
people out of the left and ensuring the
trump will win again in 2020 ultimately
I think they are ensuring that our
country will only become more polarized
into this us versus them mentality.
Yeah.
You see the reason I don't think that's
so much unconscious as the women's
studies websites all say,
if you go read them,
they're out to destroy the patriarchy,
which is basically indistinguishable
from Western civilization,
so it's not so sure to clear me that
it's unconscious.
I think they are propelling the very old
right that they see to oppose for many
of these people in my timeline,
this is their career.
They are all churning out online article
after article right now about how racism
is to blame for the election and if you
think anything else,
you're a racist about how white people
need to wear a safety pin to show their
allies about how white people need to
take the safety pins off now because
it's embarrassing and only shows that
they want validation for being good
white people.
Piece upon piece about something so
trivial as a safety pin and I see
countless privileged sjws in my timeline
wringing their hands and posting long
status updates,
asking how to be the best ally they can
to more marginalized folks and how these
contradictory articles or confusing
them.
Well of course they are.
If you're only waiting to be told how to
be a good human being because you bought
into the idea that you're privileged,
presents you from your right to your own
opinions and choices,
then you will be pulled by each and
every contradictory and incendiary
opinion piece like this.
I'm sorry for the long winded email we
started off as a simple thank you.
I started watching your videos a little
before the election because I saw folks
in my timeline labeling you a
transphobic and I looked a little deeper
only to be surprised that I disagreed
with them.
From there,
I started listening to some of your
lectures while at the gym.
I particularly enjoyed the tragedy
versus evil talk and the Cain and Abel.
Ella.
Gloria stayed with me for weeks now in
almost every choice I make ass as it
should and I am learning to live well,
being vulnerable to unravel what I
actually believe about things
independent of this sg w ideology I have
been subscribing to for so long.
I now see that it's not so different
than the conservative fundamentalist
ideology I was raised in and took
several years to shed in my teens.
I don't think I understood the full
meaning of that Nietzsche quote.
He who fights with monster should be
careful lest he thereby become a monster
and if thou gaze long into an abyss,
the abyss.
We'll also gaze into the,
until I began listening to your lectures
and reflecting on the actions I've seen
in my community slash echo chamber
recently,
so thank you for that to finally,
I am sure you have many people assisting
you and I'm going to contribute to your
patriot,
but if you ever need additional help,
especially on any of the sjw magic words
and conversation stopping tactics,
let me know.
I have lived without ideology as my
religion for so many years and I know
the language well.
Well that's an excellent letter and so
thank you very much to the writer of
that letter who I've taken some pains to
disguise.
Here's something that Milton Friedman
said about inequality.
Uh,
Milton Friedman was someone,
the Economist magazine called the most
influential economists,
the second half of the 20th century.
He's often put into the conservative
camp of,
of economists,
a society that puts equality before
freedom will get neither a society that
puts freedom before he quality.
We'll get a high degree of both.
Well,
something to think about.
Now I should also say that the anti pc
stickers are still for sale.
I'll put the link back below the apse in
development and that was the APP that
will help us locate where the bulk of
poster activity is that's associated
with politically correct activity.
And we have a web page and development.
The idea for the web pages to allow
people to upload policy documents from
companies and other institutions as well
as governments that are fundamentally
politically correct in the origin,
and to track their developmental course
so that we can start to figure out who's
behind these sorts of things and what
might be done to stop them.
So anyways,
that's all for now.
I hope that you are able to tune into
the debate.
Uh,
just a reminder that's Saturday,
November 9th at 9:30 AM eastern standard
time,
and it will be livecast on Jordan
Peterson videos.
Thank you very much for watching.
Bye Bye.